- I want the young people to understand
how to manage the failure.
If you want to be innovators
I'm going to give you
what type of characteristic you must have.
See, I have a feeling
whenever I do something
I feel happy.
You, you want to be you?
- [Audience] Yes.
- Not anybody else.
By breaking their limits
of their imagination
they change the world.
Creativity, at least to think.
When he enters the classroom my teacher,
I see a radiation of purity of life.
A leader should work with integrity
and succeed with integrity.
- Sir, how did you become so great?
- How did I become so great?
That's the question.
When there is order in the nation,
there is peace in the world.
- He was the eleventh president of India
from 2002 to 2007.
- A career scientist turned politician.
He studied physics and
aerospace engineering.
- He was intimately
involved in Indian civilian
space program and missile defense systems.
- He's A.P.J. Abdul Kalam
and here are his top
ten rules for success.
- We should know how to handle the,
not only how to handle the success,
how to handle the failures.
Particularly, you are in
the management environment,
here at Wharton, yet I
want the young people
to understand how to manage the failure.
Because you need to ask, you do,
you are to come across problems.
Problems should not become the captain
of the individual or project chief.
And the project chief
should become the captain
of the problems and defeat
the problem and succeed.
If you want to be discoverers,
if you want to be innovators,
I'm going to give you
what type of characteristic you must have.
Invention and discoveries have
emanated from creative minds
that have been constantly working
and imagine the outcome, the telephone,
he was imagine the outcome.
Imagine the outcome in the mind
with the imagine of constant effort
all the forces of the universe
work for that inspired mind,
thereby, leading to invention discoveries.
See, I have a feeling.
whenever I do something, I feel happy.
You see, this is you trying.
And that whatever you may have knowledge
you hope sometime better
economy you may have,
because sometimes you can
have kind words you can have.
So if you use and make
somebody's life happy,
that is you're giving, and
his or her life is happy,
that's the best thing a
human being can think of.
Then you get a conflict-free world.
I learn.
What did I learn from the
youth of 11 million people?
I learned your very
youth wants to be unique.
Your very youth wants to be unique.
That is you.
Whoever the youth who are
to be unique, that is you.
But the world around you is doing it best
day and night to make you
just like everybody else.
(audience claps)
Now, the question is whether
you want to be you or everybody else.
You, you want to be you?
- [Audience] Yes.
Not everybody else.
Now the question be like everybody else
is convenient at the first
glance, but not transferring
in the long vision.
The challenge, therefore,
my young friends,
is that you're to fight
the hardest battle.
You're to fight the hardest battle
which any human being can
ever imagine to fight.
And never stop fighting
until you arrive at
your destined place,
that is the unique you.
History has proven, history has proven,
that those who dare to
imagine the impossible
are the ones who break
all the human limitations.
There are very few human in the world,
whether science, medicine,
sports, or the technology,
the names of the people, just now I listed
some of the names, the names of the people
imagined the impossible are
engraved in our history.
By breaking the limits
of their imagination,
by breaking the limits
they change the world.
You take C.V. Raman, you take Newton,
you take Einstein, you take Chandrashekar,
by breaking the limits
of their imagination
they changed the world.
Learning, learning use creativity.
Creativity leads to thinking.
Thinking provides knowledge.
Knowledge makes you great.
- You have many accomplishments.
You've written books,
you've served as president,
you're an aerospace engineer,
you've been a professor,
but you say the title you
like best is the title
of teacher, why is that?
- You know, I had a
teacher when I was a young
boy, ten years boy, wartime,
the second world war going on.
At that time, I used to see in my class,
fifth class teacher, in science teacher,
his name was Siva Subramaniam Iyer.
He entered the classroom,
and we used to see
the radiation of knowledge from him.
Radiation of knowledge from him.
When he enters the classroom, my teacher,
I see radiation of purity of life.
And the way he taught
my dream was got shaped,
what should be my way of life.
He is the person, the
teacher, gave me the vision
of my life when I was a young fellow.
Now, a teacher has got
the fantastic opportunity
to grow minds, to interest
the minds and give the
dreams to the young people
and nurture the dreams
with them and they will
become a great human being.
Sometime they will become better than you.
Better than the teacher.
So that opportunity you have.
And also the teacher, like what I'm doing,
I'm a professor, I can
also do the research,
young researchers will be work with me.
That's a great pleasure
when they get their PhD.
Every action of the leader
should be transparent.
You know what I mean.
Every leader should work with integrity
and succeed with integrity.
Leader should work with integrity
And I believe president, since you asked
the question, has to be
continuously in touch
with the people.
Ramanathapuram, when I was
there, became a people's power.
Ramanathapuram, it becomes people's power.
And also, I travel into the whole state
cutting across hills, deserts and seas.
I was in touch with millions
and millions of people.
- Sir, how did you become so great?
(audience laughing)
- How did I become so great?
That's the question.
Well, which class are you sitting?
- Fourth.
- What is your dream in life?
- I want to become a singer.
- Singer.
(audience applauding)
Any music?
- Yeah, any music.
- Any music.
Well, I don't know how
I became (laughing).
You know, these are relative terms.
So, I personally believe
you must have a dream,
say it.
I must have a dream.
- I must have a dream.
- I must continuously acquire knowledge.
- Hard work.
Hard work.
- And perseverance.
- One should not be afraid of problems.
- Not afraid of problems.
- Then you will be successful, okay?
As we say in India,
where there is righteousness in the heart,
there is beauty in the character.
When there is beauty in the character,
there is harmony in the home.
When there is harmony in the home,
there is an order in the nation.
When there is order in the nation,
there is peace in the world.
(audience applauds)
- Mr. President Abdul Kalam,
in the name of the European Parliament
I want to thank you for this important
and inspiring speech.
This was one of the most
extraordinary speeches
we have ever heard.
(audience applause)
From a statesman, scientist
and poet, this is unique.
All the best to this great nation, India.
All the best to our cooperation
between the great nation
India and the European Union.
All the best, Mr. President.
- Thank you so much for watching.
- We made this video because
Ravi Chandra asked us to.
Once again, if you have
a famous entrepreneur
that you want us to profile,
please leave it below.
- I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
that we mentioned today
meant the most to you,
had the biggest impact,
leave in the comments
we'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe.
And we'll see you soon.